im rathaus von melle wird das
öffentliche leben auch viele kleine
ortsteile organisiert einer davon ist
oldendorf und da gibt es freiwillige
feuerwehr kameraden die ziemlich sauer
sind auf die aus dem rathaus und was das
problem ist stellen sie gerne nach denn
jeder soll wissen was hier schief
gelaufen ist das brandneue feuerwehrauto
passt nicht ins gerätehaus weil die
stadt das versprechen eine größere halle
zu bauen seit vielen jahren nicht auf
die reihe bekommt das gebäudemanagement
hier meldet erscheint noch nicht so
richtig zu funktionieren also solche
sachen kann man im vorfeld eigentlich
mal vernünftig planen ist so weiß ich
nicht wir haben also keine konkreten
antworten warum wieso weshalb man sagt
immer es ist eine hohe
arbeitsverdichtung und ja man könnte das
angeblich nicht abarbeiten oder also
konkret dass man sagt woran es jetzt
hart oder scheitert wissen wir nicht der
anbau sollte eigentlich längst fertig
sein die pläne dafür gibt es schon lange
immer wieder hatte die feuerwehr den
kauf eines neuen spritzen fahrzeugs
verschoben
als es dann vor rund vier jahren die
zusage für den neubau gab wurde es
endlich bestellt 130000 euro hat es
gekostet nun ist es da aber die neue
halle ist immer noch nicht fertig wir
haben mittlerweile so eine art
galgenhumor irgendwie motivieren und so
gegenseitig damit nicht wirklich nur
einer die klamotten den nagel hängt
anders ist das kommt noch zu ertragen so
lange wartezeit problem ist in
deutschland ja hinsichtlich bekannt dass
vieles gemacht wird und dann erst
nachher überlegt wird
wann ist fertig wie läuft so was
auf anfrage teilt die stadt in einer
e-mail mit bald soll es los gehen die
arbeiten seien bereits ausgeschrieben
vor diesem hintergrund wird die
einweihung des anbaus voraussichtlich im
frühjahr 2009 10 erfolgen
bis dahin müssen die kameraden mit ihren
über 30 jahre alten einsatzfahrzeug
vorlieb nehmen
der 130 tausend euro teure neue
spritzenwagen steht in einem
angemieteten schuppen weit weg vom
gerätehaus da passt er zwar ein ist aber
für schnelle einsätze nicht verfügbar
und kann vorerst nur zu übungszwecken
genutzt werden